[Aplausos]
[Música]
el euro es como el líder de las divisas
a todo el mundo le encanta criticarlo
pero a la hora de la verdad mucha más
gente de la que pensamos termina
utilizándolo estoy seguro de que todos
vosotros habéis escuchado a economistas
y expertos de todo tipo predecir el fin
de la moneda única europea
lo mejor que podría hacer alemania para
europa sería abandonar la moneda única
pero no lo hará la rey elliot para the
guardian el euro es flagrantemente
imperfecto desde su construcción y sus
arquitectos ya lo sabían en el momento
de su creación
george soros sin embargo la realidad es
muy distinta al final de este vídeo vais
a ver cómo el euro es tan sólido como el
dólar estadounidense prueba de ello es
que a día de hoy es la segunda divisa de
reserva internacional creéis que estoy
loco para
la tercera parte del comercio
internacional se realiza utilizando el
euro como moneda de intercambio el 20
por ciento de las divisas de reserva de
los bancos centrales están denominadas
en euros y el euro es la divisa en la
que muchos países emiten su deuda
pero aquí no termina la cosa si seguís
visual polític todas las semanas ya
sabéis que donald trump está poniendo
toda clase de aranceles contra el
comercio internacional y eso qué
significa pensadlo bien si eeuu va a
comprar menos cosas en el extranjero
habrá menos dólares en circulación sin
embargo aquí no adivina quién está
firmando pactos de libre comercio con
todo hijo de vecino exacto la unión
europea ya han aprobado un tratado con
canadá el llamado zeta pero no es el
único en los últimos dos años
europa ha reducido aranceles con japón
méjico y muchos otros países
[Música]
en otras palabras cuanto más cosas
compramos en el extranjero más euros
habrá circulando por el mundo es decir
que puede que lleguemos a un punto donde
en lugar de tener una divisa hegemónica
tengamos dos el dólar estadounidense y
el euro y ya sé lo que estáis pensando
todo esto para qué sirve de verdad es
útil que el euro sea la divisa
hegemónica o una de las divisas
hegemónicas pues sí y a la vez no si
eres europeo y por ejemplo tienes una
empresa el hecho de que el euro pueda
ser la divisa hegemónica te afecta más
viento
[Música]
ahora bien para los gobiernos europeos
es una ventaja descomunal si hay mucha
demanda de euros el banco central
europeo tiene mayor margen para imprimir
dinero sin que se devalúe la moneda de
todas formas todo esto lo explicamos
mejor en nuestro vídeo sobre el dólar si
no lo habéis visto todavía encontrareis
el link en la descripción porque la
pregunta de este vídeo es qué ventajas
tiene el euro sobre cualquier otra
divisa por ejemplo que tiene el euro y
no tenga el yuan chino y lo que es más
importante porque tantos economistas
critican al euro y porque creemos que se
equivocan hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
crisis existencial en los años 70 a los
países europeos ya comerciaban entre
ellos con toda la comodidad del mundo
todavía no existía la unión europea pero
teníamos una cosa muy parecida el
mercado común sin embargo había un
problema cada país tenía su propia
divisa y cada divisa funcionaba de un
modo totalmente distinto por ejemplo el
marco alemán era una moneda fuerte y
estable sin embargo la liga italiana
estaba devaluando se continuamente así
que imagínate la situación eres un banco
alemán y le prestas un millón de liras a
una empresa italiana en ese momento el
millón de liras se cambia por mil marcos
alemanes sin embargo cuando la empresa
te va a devolver el dinero la liga se ha
devaluado
así que aunque te devuelvan un millón de
liras cuando lo cambias a tu moneda te
dan 900 marcos alemanes
vamos que has hecho el negocio del siglo
pues bien para evitar esto los políticos
europeos se juntaron en una habitación y
por lo visto probaron sustancias un poco
raras
[Música]
y llegaron a un acuerdo titulado la
serpiente monetaria en el túnel
la serpiente representa las
fluctuaciones de las divisas que suben y
bajan como una serpiente pero para que
no suban y bajan demasiado entonces
ponemos un túnel en fin eran los años 70
una época muy loca donde bob marley
estaba vivo y la gente llevaba
pantalones de campana
conclusión sirvió está
cosa para algo obviamente no las divisas
subían y bajaban como si fueran una
serpiente borracha y décadas más tarde
los políticos europeos se volvieron a
sentar esta vez era el año 1992 y a este
acuerdo le pusieron un nombre como dios
mango lo llamaron el tratado de
maastricht y aquí sí que se pusieron
serios y dijeron se acabó la tontería
vamos a crear una divisa única para
todos fuera tasas de intercambio
fluctuaciones y mandangas ley del gran
bretaña que tú no quieres que te quieres
quedar con la esterlina para un desa
pues mira gran bretaña a lo que te dé la
lo que te dé la gana mira vete por ahí a
conducir por el lado de la carretera y
déjanos vivir y así es como comenzó un
proceso de tres etapas para crear la
moneda única en el año 1999 todas las
bolsas europeas ya cotizaban en euros y
poco tiempo más tarde los ciudadanos
europeos empezamos a utilizar la moneda
única para
y aquí es donde comenzaron las primeras
críticas
[Música]
europa ejemplifica una situación
desfavorable para una moneda común está
compuesta de naciones distintas que
hablan distintos idiomas y tienen
distintas fronteras con ciudadanos que
tienen más lealtad a su propio país que
a un mercado común oa la idea de europa
milton friedman y os preguntaréis pero
cuál es el problema con una moneda única
que tenía milton friedman contra el euro
pues muy fácil si tenemos una moneda
única ese banco alemán del que
hablábamos antes ya no tiene problemas a
la hora de prestar dinero a la empresa
italiana o griega qué ocurre entonces
que como no hay riesgo de divisa los
bancos alemanes que tienen mucho dinero
se lo prestan a las empresas italianas
griegas o españolas que lo necesitan
[Música]
de repente los países ricos se dedican a
invertir en los países pobres como si no
existiera mañana y os preguntaréis dónde
está el problema pues el problema llega
con la crisis
los alemanes deberán aceptar mayores
pérdidas en los préstamos griegos dice
el ministro de finanzas alemán
básicamente las economías del sur de
europa son más pobres y más débiles
cuando llega una crisis sus empresas son
las primeras en caer y si una empresa no
puede devolver los préstamos el banco
puede caer también a esto lo llamamos el
riesgo de contagio y eso explica que
durante la crisis hubiera tantos
políticos y economistas que proponían
abandonar el euro muchos llegaron a
hablar de crear dos divisas distintas un
euro para los países ricos que sería
sólido y estable y un euro para los
países pobres un euro que se podría
devaluar como si no existiera mañana sin
embargo a día de hoy el euro sigue vivo
y coleando porque ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
viva el caos los críticos tienen razón
el banco central europeo bce por sus
siglas es una auténtica torre de babel
funciona de una forma parecida al
gobierno de un país el presidente que
ahora es mario draghi y su comité son el
poder ejecutivo pero también tenemos un
equivalente al poder legislativo el
llamado consejo de gobierno y aquí es
donde están los representantes de todos
los países de la zona euro- hay un
representante de españa uno de francia
uno de alemania de esloveno en fin todos
los países de la eurozona y estos son
los que realmente toman las decisiones
los que dicen si se suben o si se bajan
los tipos de interés o si se imprime más
o menos dinero y para eso lógicamente se
tienen que poner de acuerdo
[Música]
y aquí es donde viene el problema los
países del sur de europa quieren
normalmente imprimir más dinero y los
del norte pues no no quieren imprimir
dinero y como no se ponen de acuerdo es
casi imposible hacer decisiones
drásticas todo esto es cierto el
problema es
dónde está el problema dónde está el
problema en que una moneda no pueda
evaluarse porque en los que la imprimen
no se ponen de acuerdo no sería más bien
una ventaja
pues no hemos dicho mil veces aquí en
visual político la mejor divisa es la
que menos cambia si el valor del dinero
es estable tú puedes hacer tus compras
sin miedo a que suban los precios de un
día para otro
tú puedes montar tu empresa tecnológica
porque sabes que puedes invertir a largo
plazo y diréis pero tan estable es el
euro pues mira de esta gráfica aquí
podéis ver la oferta de masa monetaria
lo que llamamos el índice m2 del banco
central europeo y la de la reserva
federal estadounidense
[Música]
veis cómo van prácticamente de la mano
en menos de 20 años de historia el euro
se ha convertido en una moneda tan
sólida como el dólar de hecho en europa
se nos ha olvidado completamente lo que
es la inflación para que os hagáis una
idea la reserva federal estadounidense
tiene dos grandes objetivos uno es
mantener la inflación baja pero a la vez
maximizar el empleo sin embargo el bc
sólo tiene un único objetivo estabilidad
monetaria
y las cosas como son lo han cumplido a
rajatabla así que bien podemos decir que
el euro es una moneda tan sólida y
abundante como el dólar pero podría
llegar a ser incluso más sólida y
abundante y la respuesta es que si a día
de hoy la eurozona tiene alrededor de
320 millones de habitantes casi los
mismos que eeuu y aunque la economía
euros más pobre que la norteamericana la
eurozona se puede ir ampliando a medida
que entren nuevos países en los últimos
diez años seis nuevos países se han
incorporado al euro
y aunque el clima político no es
favorable no es descabellado pensar que
países como polonia o los nórdicos
podrían terminar usando la moneda común
en un futuro por si todo esto fuera poco
hay muchas otras monedas que están
ligadas al euro recordáis este otro
vídeo donde hablábamos de las colonias
francesas en áfrica años contaba que en
países como costa de marfil o senegal
usan una divisa que se llama el franco
cf o divisa que está ligada al euro
hablamos de más de 150 millones de
personas en economías emergentes que
utilizan una divisa ligada al euro y que
guardan sus reservas o parte de ellas en
europa en otras palabras que con tanta
gente usando euros en su día a día hay
suficientes billetes como para que las
empresas todo el mundo puedan conseguir
divisas fácilmente
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando
algunos que sí que vale fonseca que hay
mucha gente usando euros pero sabes que
otra moneda se utiliza mucho el yuan
chino ese renminbi que cada día está más
de moda porque vamos a utilizar euros en
lugar de renminbi
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
los problemas del young tenéis toda la
razón
china está llena de chinos chinos y
sancho danés también llamado renminbi
para sus transacciones diarias eso
significa una demanda enorme de divisas
y divisas abundantes en principio con
esto bastaría para que joan pudiera ser
una divisa de reserva verdad bueno hay
un problema
china pone un límite equivalente a 15
mil dólares para el dinero que puede
sacar una persona con su tarjeta tal
cual como lo es a china no le gusta que
los yuanes salgan fuera del país
así que hay toda clase de controles de
capitales en otras palabras que
conseguir yuanes en el mercado
internacional no es tarea fácil lo
veíamos en este otro vídeo china quiere
evitar que los empresarios chinos saquen
su dinero del país y para eso el banco
popular chino pone toda clase de
restricciones y como os podéis imaginar
en una dictadura como china es difícil
creer en la independencia de su banco
central
[Música]
vamos que si jinping lo necesitara
podría cambiar al gobernador del banco y
ponerse imprimir billetes a su antojo no
me creéis de verdad pensáis que el
sistema político no afecta a una divisa
pues esperad a las próximas semanas
pronto vamos a sacar un vídeo hablando
sobre turquía y la megadevaluación que
están sufriendo en este vídeo vais a
descubrir lo que pasa cuando mezclas
autoritarismo y crisis económica si no
os lo queréis perder ya sabéis
suscribiros a visual político mientras
tanto os dejo con esta pregunta es que
es posible que el euro llegue a ser tan
importante como el dólar o tal vez
llegar a una nueva crisis que termine
llevándose por delante a la moneda
europea
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre recordad que
podéis apoyar este proyecto a través de
nuestra página de patrián donde además
acceder
es a contenido exclusivo y un montón de
cosas más si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like compartirlo con vuestros
amigos y nos vemos en el próximo un
abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]